Tom Holland is the best Spider-Man three
I'm not getting in trouble yeah I'm
gonna get in trouble I'm leaving it
right there Tommy wanted to just flip
the table then but I was worried the
legs might bang your feet
Doctor Strange is the worst facial hair
in the Marvel Universe
I mean well I don't know I'm not a big
facial hair guy I don't know you better
take this one I'm not I don't know I
think there's
um other facial hair that I find
um particular yeah that I that are that
that's sharp sharp sharper sharper so
and I think those are but I also am like
kind of into his look and so I'm just
gonna live in the disagree land
got to disagree because my makeup artist
is outside
he would find out and he will never ever
ever ever ever forgive me so I'm gonna
just how often how have you ever lived
with it like going up well I grew it
this time I grew it for the most part
yeah yeah not these guys but how do you
feel about it in life I mean it's a lot
it's not in the dark obviously so it
doesn't it's not such an assault right
on the census I mean it's very against
pale skin it's like what so dark who do
you think is like worse than yours never
will I ever say that about another okay
yeah horrible facial hair that grows off
of your face
it was your personal choice rather than
something that's in the comics
come on bring me another table and I
will slide that come on don't do this
don't do this that's that's not either
commit or don't this is not no no
I say this I disagree
yeah iconic iconic you want to go iconic
yeah yeah all right listen Batman and
Superman are like the biggest
superheroes on the planets Kryptonite as
a term is just used freely I don't even
think there's a copyright on it I think
like any sitcom can be like oh no that's
my kryptonite oh no he's my kryptonite
She's My Kryptonite you can just say
that you know why that's osmosis into
like social into society that's like the
idea is just like they're saying like
I'm retreating to my Batcave you don't
have to be Batman to say that because
these things have seeped into society
they are we are one with them
these are iconic moments this guy you
talk about iconic things okay cool
1941 yes we had Captain America punches
like a punch and Hitler it was so good
they did it again for issue two but in a
different angle yeah they did it did it
yeah that's iconic iconic itself
Superman is fortnite season I call it
characters yeah who is more iconic than
Superman how many people was he oh
must be how can that you know people can
see them things that's true that's a
good point
when they when they talk about okay fair
enough we're gonna talk about science
first people we think about is Tony
Stark they don't talk about Batman
Batman's not a scientist well he does
science type of things with technology
all the time
he has a lot of gadgets only known who
Tony Stark is for 13 years like before
2007. it's still iconic how many people
you see not as iconic as a character
who's been around for over 17. I mean
since black panther came out now how
many people you see God what kind of
forever what kind of forever how many
times like you and maybe like six or
seven other people I'm lying that's
terrible
no I'm so sorry Captain America has the
best suit of any superhero three two one
I I have I mean look I'm obviously a
little biased but we have to we have to
play
bye-bye our truths that it's not the
truth it's not that's not the truth it's
not the truth not the truth
it's the suit for him and it works for
him but if we're measuring against all
the Avengers let's be honest it's not
the best
I mean [ __ ] they're all better than mine
whether it's whether it's Scarlet
whether it's Hemsworth whether it's Tom
Holland I mean they they all wear Tom
does a great job with his suit he does
he pulls it off he really does yeah
where I strongly agree is how nice it is
to work compared to a lot of other
costumes which are not so nice yeah I
agree it's good I also think that there
are some very nice other costumes
because there are talented costumes and
designers all across the Spectrum but I
would have to say that I agree this is
like doing a Ouija board or something
the keep is special it's a clue yes the
cloak cloak cloak sorry excuse me
witches to wear it depends on what
position I am I need to be in where my
hook points for my wires are we're
constantly in harnesses yeah underneath
these costumes yeah this is true and
that's a special feeling
I'm glad I have a looser fit that's
another honestly this is where I get
because for me pragmatically it is far
less uncomfortable than what most people
have to go through and let alone getting
into Iron Man jams and all that stuff I
like painting your face or something I
mean you know you could get up at three
o'clock in the morning or most of these
shows
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
alone don't do this because you know
let's go let's go here Spider-Man's real
guys Gallery Rivals Batman's Rose
Gallery hands down Rivals you didn't you
couldn't even bring yourself to say
beats because it doesn't it rolls it it
does actually I'm not here about Rivals
I'm here about Batman's is better no
it's not Spiderman Spiderman
come on all right come on hit me come on
let's do it let's do it let's go for the
sake for just to be generous to you as
an act of Charity I'm gonna take Joker
off the table okay that's how much I
believe in this one that's how much I
believe most Marvel villains are just
dark versions of the hero so like even
if you want to go with MCU I can list
off to you the amount of MCU movies but
we're in the first movie the bad guy at
the end of it is just the good guy in a
dark costume
okay like a lot of the there's a lot
more Intrigue I would say from some of
the decisions
that's what he is he's got the same
person
but he's not Superman's biggest villain
is he he's like that's Lex Luthor which
is actually an incredibly interesting
idea that the most powerful man and you
use Jesse who to play him you might as
well call him with the light Jesse
Eisenberg yeah
he's a sick actor don't the red keeps
her coming
yeah that was mildly oh my God oh my God
I'll bring Joker back up from down here
I don't have to bring jokes
Heath Ledger and whacking Phoenix and
Jack Nicholson into this I don't need to
who's your best villain from your MCU
world are you gonna go with Mr Mr you're
gonna do this the Thanos is that is that
it no no no who is it I will say Magneto
and the reason why I say that Marco fast
Ben die did he Justice
those movies didn't though
the best Spider-Man three I'm not
getting in trouble yeah I'm gonna get in
trouble I'm leaving it right there Tommy
wanted to just flip the table I was
worried the legs might bang your feet
um
right there just leave it up to the
people
best quality
sorry that's quite easy I know
um best quality is a Spider-Man
um I would say handsome
I would say
um I mean there's a
thank you Spider-Man I think one of them
is that you actually love being
Spider-Man yeah like and you embrace it
so much I think anyone who's ever seen
him you know deal with kids especially
when he's in the out the the whole get
up you know the suit it's really special
to watch you know he does the accent and
does the web thing because I was like
can you shoot a web he's like I've used
all my web cartridges getting here you
know it's it's really really sweet you
know um he has this annoying capability
of being able to do everything really
well so it's like when you're when
you're watching him flip and then land
and then fight and then do all these
things you know you're you're great at
it and you do it with such ease
chairs
still on Netflix would be doctor strange
in a fight three two
I mean you know there's no there's no
messing around this this is the
all-powerful I'm nearly tagging along
for the ride
I just I just think she's the strongest
yeah she is she is yeah and I'm fine
with that do you think she's the
strongest Avenger I do
I know there are debates online but I do
I like American football I just don't
understand why it's called football
because they don't use their feet yeah
it should be causing different
throw ball whatever you want to call it
but you don't kick it
what once yeah